- [Voiceover] What I
want to do in this video
is give ourselves some
practice constructing
expressions with exponents
to solve real problems.
So let's start looking
at these real problems.
So this first one says the surface area
of a cube is equal to the sum of the areas
of its six sides, and that makes sense
if I were to draw a cube here.
If I were to draw a cube,
it has six sides, it has the three sides
we see right over here,
one, two, three, and
it has the three sides
that we don't see, if we were
to make this a transparent cube
then we could count those as well,
so the one in the back here,
one in the back there, and then
the bottom right over here.
So you have six sides of
a cube, we believe that,
and it says, Spencer has
two cube shaped blocks
that he wants to paint.
One cube has sides of length four units.
One cube has sides of length four units,
so let's say that this is
this one right over here.
So it's a cube, so all of these dimensions
are four units.
The other cube has lengths
of sides 2.5 units,
so the other cube is going
to look something like this.
The other cube looks something like this,
and the sides are 2.5, 2.5, 2.5.
Write a numerical expression
with exponents for the total surface area
he has to paint.
Well, there's six sides here,
and what's the area of
each of the six sides?
So there's six sides like this,
so there's going to be six times
the area of each side, and what's the area
of each side?
Well, each side is going
to be four by four,
each side is a four by four square.
So each side is going to have an area
of four squared.
So the surface area of the six sides
of this cube, is six times four squared.
Once again, the surface area,
or the area of each side,
is going to be four squared,
and there's six of them,
so that's the surface area of this cube,
and then the same logic
for the surface area
of this cube.
The area of each of the sides
is going to be 2.5 times 2.5,
or we could write that as
2.5 to the second power,
and there's going to be
six sides to the cube,
so it's going to be six times 2.5 squared,
so a numerical expression
with exponents for the total
surface area he has to paint,
well that's the surface
area of both cubes,
this is the surface
area of the yellow cube,
this is the surface area of the blue cube,
and we are done.
And just as a reminder on a little bit
of the notation I'm using,
this is not a decimal, this is higher
than a decimal, it's kind
of halfway up the numbers,
and when I write it like that,
that's a way of writing multiplication,
and you're going to see that more and more
as you go into algebra.
I could have also written it this way,
I could have written it as six times four
squared, plus, six times
2.5 squared.
This would have been
another way to write it,
and here, when you just
write another number
next to the parentheses,
it means multiply by
whatever's in the parentheses,
so this is six times four squared,
this is six times four squared.
So while we're constructing
these exponent expressions
it's also good to get used
to some of this notation.
So let's do another one,
in fact, let's do two more.
Boom Town was established in a remote part
of the world in 2010.
Its population has tripled,
let me underline that,
its population has tripled every year
since its founding.
If there were 1,050 people
in Boom Town when it was established,
let me write that down.
So there's 1,050 people in Boom Town
when it was established,
what would be the
population after six years?
So remember, after every year it triples.
So after the first year,
we're going to multiply it by three,
we're going to have three
times the population.
The second year, multiply it by three,
third year, fourth year,
fifth year, and sixth year.
Or, maybe the easier way,
or more compact way of writing this is,
its population after six years
is going to be its initial population,
times three to the sixth power.
We have six, we have six threes
that we're multiplying together.
Times three to the sixth power,
or, just as we just talked about,
the initial population, 1,050 people,
times three to the sixth power.
And the whole point here
is not to evaluate these things,
but just to construct the expression,
to know that we could evaluate this,
and actually figure out the exact answer,
but all they're asking us for
is write a numerical
expression with exponents
to describe the population of Boom Town
after six years, and we just did that.
Let's do one more of these,
this is strangely fun (chuckles)
So we have a square wall with sides
of length four meters.
Let's draw our square wall with sides
So it's a square wall.
I'm sensing a lot of
squares in this exercise
or these exercises.
So I have a square wall
with sides of length four meters,
so this is four meters,
and this is four meters.
And it has three square windows.
It has three square windows,
let me do this in a different color.
It has three square windows
each with sides of length 1.5 meters.
So it might look like this.
One square window,
another square window,
and another square window,
and these are each 1.5 by 1.5.
Lena, or Lena, wants to paper the wall,
so she needs to determine the area
of the wall that does
not include the windows.
Write a numerical
expression with exponents
that describes the area
in square meters of the wall
that Lena wants to paper.
So that's going to be all this stuff
that I am shading in blue.
Essentially the area of the larger wall,
minus the area of those three windows.
And, so what's that going to be?
Well, the area of the larger wall
is going to be four times four,
we can just write that as
four to the second power
or four squared.
The reason why people even call it
four squared, is because that's how
you figure out the area of a square.
Four squared, and then
you want to subtract out
the area of these three windows.
So there's three windows,
each of them have an area of 1.5 squared.
This area is 1.5 squared,
1.5 times 1.5, this area
is 1.5 times 1.5,
this area is 1.5 times 1.5.
So you get four squared minus
three times 1.5 squared.
And there you go, that's going
to be the area that she wants to paper.